A year ago this week the World Health
Organization declared COVID-19 a pandemic.
While China deserves primary blame for the
devastation, the WHO was a key player unwilling to
blame Beijing for its lack of transparency. The WHO
failed in its primary responsibility: to warn the
world of the pandemic risk. Even while the disease
forced lockdowns across China, the WHO hesitated
to declare COVID a public health emergency. And
when the group's director, who was, by the way,
Beijing's candidate for the position, finally made
the declaration, he echoed China's talking points,
praising the country, while ignoring that Beijing
silenced doctors. To regain credibility it's
vital that the WHO implement reforms, including
determining what went wrong through a timely and
impartial investigation, taking the process
from declaring a public health emergency
out of the hands of bureaucrats, insulating the
health emergency program from political pressure,
and matching resources to priorities. Absent
reform it will be each nation for itself.
Should the united states do more to
reform the World Health Organization?
Let us know in our poll. Also, let us know
what other topics you'd like our scholars
to cover in 60 seconds, and be sure to like and
subscribe for more research and videos from AEI.